welcome back everyone so now we're very
lucky to have Connecticut Audrey from
UCSB Dominica is an expert in many
domains in the learning and private
machine learning clustering and today
she's gonna tell us about
nearest-neighbor so more the classical
today and more more related to other
sorry Thomas okay thanks thanks very
much and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me and putting up this great
program so what I'm going to do over
today and tomorrow is that I'm going to
talk you know change tracks a little bit
from deep learning and talk a little bit
about nonparametric s-- and the reason
you know I feel that nonparametric sar
particularly interesting is that you
know as you have seen throughout this
program there are some nice recent
connections right so you know for
example either Misha or Daniel you know
I mean there's some nice connections
between regimes where deep learning does
interpolation and you know behaves sort
of like nonparametric right and so this
has kind of led to a renewed interest in
this area and what I'm going to do is
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about the more classical stuff so I have
on you know K nearest neighbors and then
regression and classification so we are
going to talk a little bit about the
more classical stuff what is known what
can be achieved stuff like this and the
some of this this is based on my own
work and some of it is basically
classical work for K nearest neighbors
tomorrow we are going to change tracks
and we are going to talk about some
recent work that we have done on
adversarial examples right so we are
going to talk about adversarial examples
for K nearest neighbors so when you know
what can we say about adversarial
examples there when it's when it's a
robust stuff like that and then towards
the end tomorrow we are going to go and
talk about more general nonparametric
adversarial examples for more general
nonparametric sand these are some very
new results that we have on how
adversarial examples behave
quite a bit differently for non-vital
metrics than okay so what is K nearest
neighbor so this is you know one of the
simplest kind of pattern recognition
methods right so from you know back in
the 50s right so what happens is you're
given training data x1 y1 2 x and y n
your X lies in some sort of space X and
let's say your neighbors lie in 0 1
although it lends itself very nicely
when you have a certain more than one
labels as well and basically what you
want to do is you want to predict Y for
for you know you're given a query point
X and you want to predict a Y for X
based on the kid closest neighbors of X
among the training data right so what
you do is you have your X you look at
what are the key closest neighbors of X
among the training data you do some
processing and then you are predict you
know predict the Y for X based on just
these you know just these points right
and you can do a whole bunch of things
so an example would be clear and sniper
classification where what you would be
doing is it would predict the majority
label of the K closest neighbors right
or you can have a weighted majority
labels there is like you know the
weights could be based on distances
there's like any number of any number of
such example any number of schemes that
you could come up with and you know K
nearest neighbor regression you can also
talk about you know you predict the
average label of your K closest
neighbors and notice that what when I
talk about closest what I am assuming is
that there is some underlying metric
space right so what we assume for K
nearest neighbors is your data points
lie in some underlying metric space and
there is some underlying distance
function D so between any pair of points
X and X Prime there's a distance and you
know this distance could be really
anything right so if you have so you can
think about your instance space as being
you know R to the D and after the
capital D and your D could be the a
their distance or it could be any other
the distance or it could be some you
know specific distances that is
application-specific right so for
example you could have you know users
giving preferences for objects and you
can have a metric that's based on these
user preferences right or you can have
you know so there's a there's a whole
bunch of things that you could do and
that is what makes this algorithm very
powerful because you know you can have
your favorite metric and you can have
your favorite objects and you can use
this out and here is a notation that I
am going to use because it will make my
life simple and I'm just putting this up
but you will see this quite a bit so X
superscript I of X means the ayat'
nearest neighbor of X right so these are
you know the order you know think about
them as order statistics right is the
kind of notation we use for all the
statistics X superscript I of X is Diet
nearest neighbor of x and y I of
superscript I of X is the label of the
side nearest me so this is something
that we'll be using okay so I am going
to put and this is what we are gonna do
today so today we are going to start
with nearest neighbor regression we'll
talk about what the setting is we'll
talk about some universal consistency
results and in some rates of convergence
and then you know we'll look at similar
things for classification okay so let's
start with the regression setting so
let's say we have some compact metric
space X X with our distance D right with
the distance function D and for now
imagine we have a measure mu 1 X and for
now imagine this is the uniform measure
so whatever I'm going to say will work
if you're within constant factors of the
uniform measure you know things well it
would depend on what this constant is
right but let's let's just you know just
to keep things simple for now imagine we
have a uniform measure V 1 X and what we
have for nearest neighbor regression is
we have our input is a whole bunch of we
have a training a bunch of training data
points x1 y1 to x and y n where the x
i's are drawn from this measure mu and
our Y eyes is some function f of X I
plus noise right and this function f is
our
right so this F we do not know what this
function f is it's some underlying
function your X I comes from you why I
is f of X I plus knots right and here
what we are hoping to do is we are
hoping to predict well okay and the way
we will do this prediction with you know
we are hoping to predict well so we are
given an unknown X we hope to predict Y
for this X so that it's close to that
should Y right and what we will use for
this is the K nearest neighbor
regression which is so I'm going to call
this the F hat K of X right so this is
you know the the K nearest neighbor
regression estimator this is 1 over K I
sum of I goes from 1 to K Y of X right
so you look at the K closest nearest
neighbor key closest neighbors of X you
look at the labels you average up the
labels that's it simplest thing
imaginable okay so the first question
that we are going to ask is you know so
we have this function what kind of
function can be approximate well right
using this kind of K nearest neighbors
and the interesting thing is that we can
basically approximate any F right any F
can be approximated well provided key
grows suitably with N and this is a
result you know this is just one in a
series of results so there's a whole
bunch of results like this for various
you know over various metric spaces
under various conditions so this is kind
of one of the more general results by
Deborah at all but essentially if you
have any F provided your K is growing
suitably with N and certain conditions
hold
you can approximate that then by K is
never regret and so what do I mean by
this so let's look at more formally
let's look at a theorem so essentially
the you need the following conditions so
you need as your n grows you need your K
n to go to infinity so if you are doing
K nearest neighbors
you need the key right K n is you know
when K grows with that you need your TN
to go to infinity and you need your KN
over N to go to 0 right if these two
conditions hold then for any
you will have the following theorem and
the theorem says that expectation of X
drawn from you f of X right so remember
you have this underlying function f of X
that you didn't know - f hat of K n of X
the gap between this the expected gap
between deeds go to zero as n goes to
infinity right and this is called
universal consistency so what this means
is that K nearest neighbor regression is
universally consistent okay so why why
does this happen right let me give you
some intuition for what is going on
there as n keeps growing right as you
get more and more points what happens
over here it is remember I a talked
about how mu was the uniform measure
right so it's kind of a pencil
continuous view as n grows and grows
what happens is your nearest neighbors
so let's say if you look at your nearest
neighbor or if you look at your five
nearest neighbors they will get closer
and closer to X right and if K n is
constant right or if it grows slowly
right so slowly in the sense that K n
over N goes to zero right and this is
where this condition is important right
K n over N goal goes to zero means
you're getting more and more local then
these care nearest neighbors will also
get closer and closer to X and now if
your function f is continuous then F of
those care nearest neighbors will also
get closer to f of X and if you know
this is the this is why you need the
continuity right if your f is continuous
K nearest neighbors will also get closer
and closer to X and then if your K n
goes to infinity then if you average
right so but don't forget that you know
your labels also involve noise but if
your kin goes to infinity then if you're
averaging the Y's which is f of x i's
plus noise that would also go to FX
because the effect you know you are
averaging out noise you know an hour on
an average that would go to zero right
so as K n goes to infinity then this
average also average of the labels also
go to goes to f of X right and this is
where
that k n goes to infinity pink comes
into play and you know any f can be
approximated arbitrarily well by
continuous functions so for any F the
sort of thing will go right sorry this
sort of thing will hold and that's
that's the universal answer that that's
kind of why we had this kind of
universal consistence okay so we talked
about you know how nearest neighbor was
universally okay so any any questions so
far about it is n by n excellent
question yes so if you have T n by n
goes to zero then what that means is
kind of the ball that has probability
mass KN that ball kind of gets smaller
and smaller right so what happens is
that KN gross goes to K n over n goes to
0 you are looking at more and more local
regions of cells right your K nearest
neighbors ally in you know closer and
closer to you and that means that their
FS are also closer and closer to yours
could be the case that if we at endpoint
like increases increase n like we see
like you know like for the regions of
space rather than like more
concentration close to any point that's
an exit question so I think what you are
saying is so right that is definitely
true here so you know for these kinds of
problems the real challenge is when F
changes quite a lot right so what you
want to say is you want to approximate F
locally right so those are the kinds of
functions are looking at you are right
that as you get more and more points
like more and more regions of the space
will be covered but what that means is
in those regions you would start getting
better and better approximations
excellent question so what he's asking
is it's the noise model arbitrary I hear
what I am implicitly assuming is that
this is 0 mean noise right and zero mean
and also I guess you know any noise that
concentrates right any noise where you
know you get a some sort of central
limit theorem and exactly so you
wouldn't so then you try to do rates
then you would end up meeting more
conditions on the laws when you try to
do rates but just this for this kind of
thing you just need zero mean and you
know some sort of central limit theorem
any any more patience yes so that I'm
glad you guys asking questions okay but
okay but so we talked about Universal et
let us now go ahead and look at some
rates okay so okay so for convergence
rates so you know we talked about you
know all these asymptotes it's when n
goes to infinity what happens so on and
so forth but can we say something about
finite n right and for that for
regression actually also to some extent
for classification but for that
particularly for regression what would
happen is that we are going to need some
more assumptions and so I'm going to
start out with a couple of definitions
so we are going to call a function S and
Lipschitz if for all pairs X and X prime
f of X minus f of X prime the difference
between you know the absolute value of
this difference is at most L times the
distance between X and X prime right so
what am I saying over here what I am
saying over here is that if two points
are close their FS are also close right
which is you know not super surprising
but there is so the importance of this
assumption is that there is a global n
that bounds how close the these are
right that is kind of the key thing
that's going on over here okay
and what you can say
something like this so there's a there's
a theorem which shows something like
this and again you know this has been
shown over the years by several people
which is that if you're f you know if
your function f is n Lipschitz and if
you choose your key n in this particular
way and you know I'll come to the choice
in just a little bit then there exists a
constant C such that the you know your
expectation of X drawn from you f hat K
of X minus f of X square right
expectation of this gap squared is at
most C times n to the minus 2 over 2
plus D capital D and recall I here
capital D is your data dimension okay
and this is achieved when your K grows
in a specific way and the way in which
it grows is n to the you know some
constant and n to the 2 over 2 plus D
and you know let me point out that you
know I know I am hiding a whole bunch of
constants over here and those constants
actually hide this this right so this
this constant over here depends on L
this constant C over here also depends
on L right so that's that's what the
dependence on everything ok and so what
does this mean right so what does this
bound mean so one thing to notice is
that which is somewhat disappointing is
that there is a dependence on the
dimension right and so what that means
is that is actually a curse of
dimensionality right what people tall
the curse of dimensionality you know
things grow exponentially with the
dimension so it does depend on the
dimension which is somewhat
disappointing however you can get better
bounds for low intrinsic dimension and
you know there's there's a lot of people
who have worked on this but you know I
think one of the first such papers was
you know somebody capo to Fair has the
very nice paper in new reps 2011 where
he gave these kinds of you know very
nice bounce forward
nearest neighbor regression for lower
entrance of dimension so if your data
lies on some kind of lower dimensional
manifold then that D will become the
dimension of the manifold
manifold instead of this capital D the
other thing to notice is that here your
this particular KN n to the 2 over 2 + D
this is actually optimal right and and
the thing to notice that this is
actually pretty high right it it grows
with n but it grows you know it's not
log in right it grows pretty strongly
with n right
so if your dimension is large then I
mean obviously the dependence goes down
but it does grow just sort of polynomial
[Music]
so for regression it's an in hard for
classification it gets a lot better so
we will see that in a little but
ratification it's you know for
classification you have some good
properties for regression also there is
smoothness you can have various you know
holder continuity smoothness right
assumptions legislature does that low
intrinsic dimension result assume that
you're using certain geodesic metric
manifold you're talking about oh no no
you're using you know regular
cleanliness but that's what makes it so
interesting excellent question
[Music]
okay good okay so this is all but a
quick proof of this then you know just
you know general proof intuitions and
then we will so how fast is this
convergence well we'll we'll look at it
in two steps right so first we will look
at how small are these K nearest
neighbor distances right and then we
will look at you know how we go from
these distances to this convergence rate
so can you receive a distance says let's
let's define our key of X as the
distance to the kidney and the question
that we have is how small is this art
GFX okay so let's say if you look at an
X look at a ball of radius
you know let's look at a ball of radius
R K of X right R T of X is the distance
to the K fiercely by
if you look at the you know what I call
the empirical measure of the ball right
like the fraction of points in the ball
that's approximately K over N right if
your K and n is large and that's
approximately K over N and this is close
to and you know I'm waving my hands a
little bit around here provided your KN
and a large enough this is close to boom
of this ball right and so if you look at
this mu of this ball and if you assume
that the ball is small enough so you
know again a lot of hand waving but if
you assume this ball is small enough
then neo-marxist ball is a very
approximately you you know you look at
the ball let's say everything is more or
less the same the mu of X in that entire
ball is more or less the same this is
approximately mu of X and there should
be some constant times the kids nearest
neighbor radius ^ B right and you know
you know again this is like a very very
back of the envelope calculation but
what this means right so what this means
over here is that your are K of X right
distance to your Cape nearest neighbor
look something like this right so it's 1
over mu of X times K over N raised to
the power of 1 over D where D is the
data dimensional right and this is bad
news right because now you had the curse
of dimensionality like this is pretty
bad news
okay over the end is the is muon BX
approximately you know there are
Epsilon's and deltas but I'm just kind
of like okay so this is bad news because
we have the curse of dimensionality but
you can show that this is you know again
better for data with low entrance
intervention and as there's been some
work on this you know the costa and al
hero and richard Sam both you know
people have looked at this and you can
get better for data flow intrusive okay
so now we know how bad the nearness
leaver distances are now let us look at
how to get to how to use this okay so
remember that initially what we were
trying to do is we were trying to get
rates of convergence for K nearest
neighbor regression and now what we'll
do is we will get there right so the
first thing is you know we are doing
carrier sniper regression what we are
going to do is we are going to break
this up into our bias-variance
decomposition right so notice so we are
going to define this f tilde K of X
right and F tilde K of X is you know
notice you have the labels right so what
you were doing is you were taking the
average over the labels or average what
the Y is right and so what you're going
to do is you're going to assume that
this average is the expect you know what
you get is the expectation right so and
the difference between your f and if you
got the expected values of the Y is
right that gap squared that is your bias
right so we are going to bounce this
plus and the gap between what you really
get with the real labels minus the
expected value of the labels that is the
variance and we are going to bound this
gap right and what you can show through
some math is that you can get you know
you can look at the entire you know gap
between FK x and f of x squared you can
decompose it into these two bucks it's a
you know it's a standard bias-variance
decomposition
and now what we will do is we will bound
each of them one by one right so first
let's start out by bounding the bias you
bound the bias so this is I am just
writing down what the bias is right
because I now notice that the Y you know
this is the expected value of the wives
right so the the noise and the Y's is
gone
the noise part is gone and by your
lipschitz nests this is at most L times
this distance so each of these is at
most L times the distance between X and
the Kate nearest neighbor of x squared
right and I am you know like I'm
glossing over various constants but this
is what it is and you know each of these
and so you are you know averaging so
this is you know it's supposed to have
average and notice that you know we
talked about what the arcade distances
were and they were you know about K over
N times 1 over D and so this is you know
there's a square here so it becomes a to
go with it okay what about the variance
so variance you can also you know you
can again write this down and here it is
you know your question about what can
you say about the noise here you have to
sort of have bound and variance noise so
that that thing comes in and the
variance again you look at the so the
variance again becomes essentially the
variance of the noise and which is Sigma
Y squared over K and you can also think
about noise of you know lawn uniform
variance and defense part of space that
doesn't matter so long as the worst case
noise variance is bounded you get this
kind of thing you can even do probably
you can even do better okay okay so that
was the bias-variance decomposition so
you put everything together and you just
sort of ignore the constants which I'm
doing just for the sake of the talk what
you get is when you do this
bias-variance decomposition you would
get an expression like this right so
your radiance is about 1 over K you know
the Sigma's and stuff let's ignore them
for the moment and your bias is K over N
to the 2 over 2 over D okay and now what
you have is so so now you know I mean
this is going
but what you have is you have the power
to set key right so if you want to
optimize this bias-variance
decomposition you can set your k to be n
to the 2 over 2 plus B if you just do
some you know algebra you can see that
this is the optimal and that will give
you this rate right so you get a rate of
n to the negative 2 over 2 plus D okay
so this is kind of the main idea of the
questions over
yes there was a 1 over mu X ok it ok
good good fine that is a very good point
I think that you have raised so here we
are implicitly assuming that mu of X is
a constant right but lies between mu min
and Max and remember at the very
beginning I said that let's assume that
we are in the uniform distribution right
that's that's where it comes from
ok if you're not in the uniform
distribution there's actually a very
nice paper by a Richard Sanford which
looks into this the analysis gets much
more complicated then you can you know
still say something but you know things
are just a lot more complicated
excellent point
okay excellent questions okay so that is
more illicit for nearest-neighbor
regression so let's now look at nearest
neighbor classification so you know for
classification we are going to you know
again you know it's the same problem you
look at your the you knows we are going
to use H and K to denote the K nearest
neighbor classifier on endpoints we are
going to look at you know the so when
you give an X you're going to look at
the labels of the key points around X
and then you're going to pretty good
basically you predict the majority of
their lives right so you average the
labels average less than half you know
labels are 0 1 average is less than half
you predict 0 more than half predict 1
so and so okay good so now what are we
gonna do well we are going to look at
these things and the statistical
learning framework right so what is the
framework in which we are going to
analyze things so here is our setting
now the setting change is a little we
have a the you know the statistical
learning framework again we have
symmetric space X and E ok and now we
have again we have an underlying measure
mu on X from which points are drawn but
the important distinction is that now we
are not cancel classification has some
nice properties and it's easier than
aggression and now we are not gonna need
to assume that this measure is you know
either uniform or close to uniform right
we won't need that assumption anymore
and you know so for the regression case
we talked about you know f of X and you
know f of X plus noise now we are
talking about 0 1 right so now we have
you know the label of a point is binary
and what we are going to assume is that
it's a coin flip with bias eita of X
right so eight of X is the probability
that your Y will be 1 conditioned on X
ok so this is 8 out of X and so so
that's your setting and what do we care
about is we want to find you know the
things that we care about in a
classifier is the risk right or risk or
error which is the probability that H of
X is not equal to Y right
and why are drawn from the distribution
it's is drawn from mu and y conditioned
on X is drawn from era the risk is
probability H of X is not equal to Y and
then we have accuracy which is 1 minus
the risk right and and basically what we
want to do is we want to find an age
that maximizes risk that such that
minimizes risk or maximizes accuracy
right so that's that's kind of what we
are hoping to do okay
and you know so this is kind of
important a little bit for tomorrow
because tomorrow when we look at robust
classifiers that's not exactly the right
thing and you know we'll just remember
the slide for tomorrow ok good ok so
before I get to you know near you know
nearest neighbors let me introduce one
other thing which you know you must have
seen before which is the Bayes optimal
classifier so what is the Bayes optimal
classifier well it's the classifier
that's going to predict 0 if f of X is
less than equal to 1/2 and it's gonna
predict 1 otherwise right and so what is
the risk of this class if I really know
you can you know sit together and do the
calculation essentially the risk I you
know comes out to be something like this
right expectation over X min of 8 of X 1
minus at of X right and we are going to
call this quantity R squared R star
sorry R star right and why is this
classifier interesting well the reason
why this classifier is interesting
because this is the classifier that
minimizes risk if you have this kind of
distribution mu and mu and error no
other classifier in the world is going
to do better than this right this is the
one that absolutely minimizes risk okay
why don't we always have the Bayes
optimal well the thing to note is that
to have the Bayes optimal you need to
know what it is
right the reason why we don't have the
Bayes optimal is that you know it's a
distributor eta is a distribution
quantity and you don't know what it is
right so that's why we don't have it but
we wanted okay good so now that we have
our framework it's it's all set up for
us now let's look at what is possible so
the first question that we have is again
you know the
you know against also remember in
regression what we were doing is we were
trying to get to F right that underlying
f dollars there yeah what we are trying
to get to is the Bayes optimal that is
the goal you know that is the elusive
goal that we want right and the first
question that we are going to ask is
does R of H the risk of hn k hn case
that k nearest neighbor classifiers with
n training points and you know k
converts to our star as n grows okay so
and and you know when does it happen and
does it happen at all okay so let's
start out with trying to understand what
happens for one nearest neighbor so here
i'm going to assume you know just to
make my life simpler I'm going to assume
continuous error
I'm also going to assume absolutely
continuously okay and in that case there
is a result by cover and heart from 1967
which shows that you know this is this
is not the case at all and in fact what
you can show is that the risk of the one
nearest neighbor classifier converges to
something which looks like this this is
the expectation over F twice it it o of
x times 1 minus H of X and this is this
is not art style right so this is not
the Bayes optimal this right so what we
know over here it is that one nearest
neighbor is inconsistent and actually it
came here is me but if your K is
constant then your K nearest neighbor
will also be you know inconsistent in
the sense that it doesn't converge to
the Bayes optimal right so one here is
neighbor does not converge to the Bayes
optimal constant K also doesn't quite
converge to the Bayes optimal although
its limit is a little bit better so this
this particular limit gets better as a
grows but it doesn't converge to the
Bayes optimal okay so what what happens
over here let's try to you know let me
try to give you a little bit of
intuition right so again you know as n
is larger grows larger and larger you
know the nearest neighbor of X is going
to come closer and closer to X right so
they don't a snail's never been slowly
converge to X and since we assumed
continuity what that means is that the
eight are
that nearest neighbor is also going to
converge to their tactics okay and so
now if you look at what is happening to
the label of you know what is happening
to the label of X and a label of the
nearest neighbor you can look at what
you know what is the probability that
they are different
well that probability is at of x times 1
minus at at the nearest neighbor of X
plus at at the nearest neighbor or X so
this is like you know when eta is 0
sorry when it dies 1 the label the label
side when the label of X is 1 the level
of nearest neighbor is 0
near the label of nearest neighbor is
one label at X is 0 right that's when
they disagree and since this quantity
converges to at effects you can show
that the whole thing converges to twice
at x times 1 minus X right and so the
risk does not really converge to the
Bayes optimal it converges to this
particular thing and then for K nearest
neighbors you know you can you know for
constant K you can again do a
calculation like this and you can show
something which depends on K but again
it's not not exactly our stuff okay so
fine so constant K is not good what can
you say about growing K so about growing
K one can again show a similar result
then under that we can show under
regression what we can show is that if
it is continuous then if K n goes to
infinity and if K n over N goes to zero
then the risk of the K nearest neighbor
K nearest neighbor classifier converges
to the risk of the Bayes optimal as n
goes to infinity and this is you know
this was done in a long sequence of
results so there was a paper by you know
fix and Hodges in 1951 store looked at
it for you know R to the D over and Hart
has a series of results so this was
established for a whole bunch of metric
spaces over time okay and you know again
I can give you a little bit of intuition
it's actually the intuition is as
follows
you know it's very similar so as you
know K n grows I
as you know as n grows what happens is
your X 1 to X gain of X lie
approximately in a ball of probability
mass gain over n right and if gain over
n is 0 then you know then this radius of
this ball grows smaller and smaller and
what this means is that these new
receiver converge to X right and by
continuity director at these nearest
neighbors
you know also converge to a 12x and and
so if your K n grows then you know now
you know kind of the law of large
numbers kicks n so if you can grows then
you know you are tossing and coins each
of whose bias is very close to 8 of X
then the average also converges to
basically f of xn and you're good ok so
that's kind of the proof intuition it's
quite similar to regression ok you can
also do something which is a little bit
better and which is which is also a
little bit better essentially you can
show something much more general so you
can ask questions like you know vendors
this condition hold and you can show
something fairly general so if you have
a metric measure separable metric
measure space but you know there's this
property called the Lebed
differentiation property holds then you
can show this kind of universal
consistency and what is the lebesgue
differentiation property this property
says that for any bound and measurable F
if you look at the average of F in a
ball and the radius of this ball goes to
0 then this average converges to f of X
right as the radius of this ball goes to
0 then you can you know then you can
show Universal consistency right and you
know and this is some joint fault bits
Chandra Das Gupta from a paper in 2014
where you know so this has some other
connotations if K n goes to infinity and
cane over N goes to 0 then we can show
convergence and probability for almost
sure converges we leaned a little bit
more and we need K n over log n to go to
0 then we can also show you sigh we can
also show you almost sure converges
and this is again you know the proof is
again the idea is intuition is very
similar but the difference is the
following so earlier when we were
looking at continuity what we said was
that you know the ETA at these nearest
neighbors has to go to 8 of X right now
what we just need is that their average
has to go to it right and you know which
is a looser condition and and then
essentially that that's essentially what
this what is lebesgue differentiation
property shows so I don't want to go
into too much detail because i'm sort of
running out of time but that's that's
essentially this average differentiation
property this average property requires
that you know at off this average data
would converge to a 12x and as the
radius goes to 0 i named as the radius
and this radius will go to 0 if gain
over and goes to 0 ok
questions yes what do you know about the
final days yes that's the next one I
planted him in the audience so now let
us look at the final sample case so what
did we do before so you know before we
talked about oh if mu was smooth and you
know stuff like that so you know yeah ok
so then there's been a fair bit of prior
work on this and you know I'm not going
to go into it because a lot of it is
similar in spirit to the regression
results that I showed before right and
the main idea was that you know you
assume some sort of smoothness of MU and
then they will say oh if mu mu is small
you can get small the cicada nearest
neighbor radius and then you can talk
about Lipsius nevada and you know if it
rises Lipschitz then you know at the kid
the kid's neighbor is close to it of X
and now we can bound everything right so
which is what we did for regress and
that's what we used to bound everything
right for classification the observation
that we being it so this is a you know
joint work with Chandra Das Gupta the
observation that we made was that
neither of these things actually married
so let me show you a picture no cancer
in fact let me show you two pictures
what matters okay so let's look at this
right so here your mu is not really
smooth right this Miu you know it's like
the density is really a mess right I
know that some places is zero at some
places very high some places are very
low it doesn't really matter because
Kenya's neighbors we're gonna work
pretty well over here unless you are you
know very close to where this is and
here as well right if you look at this
again the density is you know here close
to the decision boundary the density is
really well and good but over here you
know if it's us all over the place right
it doesn't really but you know again if
you look at nearest neighbors it doesn't
really matter right
so what really matters what is you know
what really matters the nearest neighbor
classification what really matters is
what happens in balls of not a radius R
but in balls of probability mass
approximately K over N around X where X
lies close to the decision model right
so what goes on in balls or probability
mass K over N around here and maybe a
little bit wrong shape right that's all
that matters right far from the decision
boundary or Mew could be anything it
could be like you know horrible it
nobody cares right and that is kind of
the underlying basis of the nulls okay
and that's really you know that as you
will see that really clears things up
quite a bit things become really quite
clean okay okay so now that's kind of
our intuition and let's try to formalize
this okay so what we will do is we will
look at the notion of so we were looking
at K you know distance to the K nearest
neighbors you know this is a this is U K
its nearest neighbors right distance to
the nearest neighbors and we were
looking at actual distance radius now
what we will do is we will start looking
at something we call the probability
radius right so R so here P is a number
between 0 and 1 P is a probability and
the probability radius at P around X is
the following quantity it's the infimum
of the radiance such that the
probability mass at this radius is at
least P right and you know I mean just
think about this has been equal to P
right the probability mass at this
radius is equal to P I'm going to all
this infimum just to make sure things
work out okay and you know open balls
and closed balls and stuff like that but
just for now imagine that you know this
is the radius at which the probability
mass around X the ball of probability
mass R at this radius around X has like
P probability mass right and we will
also talk about conditional
probabilities for sets right so the
conditional probability of a set of
points is essentially the average it
over that set right and the average you
know so what is it that we take the
average over well we take the average
over this mu right as there was this
underlying distribution mu over X that's
what we did the average over and this is
you know a picture of this thing okay so
now with these definitions in place what
we can do is we can start talking about
so remember I you know I just kind of
showed you these pictures and Todd said
how things away from the boundary
doesn't matter right now what we will do
is we will formalize these notions okay
so we can start looking at you know
notions of interiors and boundaries so
the positive so we will look at to you
know there will be two parts the
positives and the negatives so the
positive interior is the following is
the set of all points X where X is
greater than equal to 1/2 right so this
is you know so if you took the majority
you know so if you took the right label
the right label is plus right over here
at X is greater than equal to half theta
over a ball of radius R around X is
greater than equal to half plus Delta
for all are less than equal to R P of X
right so this is this positive interior
is parameterized by two parameters P and
Delta right so P is a probability and
Delta is you know think about it as
another kind of you know so think about
it as this gap right so how far are you
from
the decision boundary so if your ax is
equal to 1/2 that's your decision
boundary of the Bayes optimal right
so think about Delta is how far are you
from the decision boundary right so
eight of X is greater than equal to 1/2
so the right label is + or 1 right and
for all are less than equal to R P of X
right at this bottom so anything within
this any ball within this probability
mass be the average ETA in any of these
balls is at least 1/2 plus Delta okay
and this is the positive integer yeah
similarly you can also define the
negative interior what will happen is
this will become less than equal to half
this will become less than equal to half
minus Delta right so that this one is
the positive part that one is the
negative part right and then anything
and then the P Delta interior is kind of
the union of these positive and negative
interiors and anything that's not in
there that's the P Delta boundary right
so anything that is left outside so you
look at your entire instance space
anything that is left outside that is
the P Delta boundary okay ok so now we
can write down the risk of the K nearest
neighbor classifier based on n training
points as a function of these interiors
and boundaries right and what we can do
is we can say that with probability at
least 1 minus Delta little Delta right
so that's actually the bet probability
at least 1 minus little Delta this risk
is at most R star remember R star was
the litter the risk of the Bayes optimal
classifier plus little Delta plus the
probability mass of this of this P Delta
bound
provided your P and Delta are set up set
appropriately okay how are you going to
set P P would be K over N times this
particular quantity right so this is you
know when your key is just sort of large
enough it's respect to so if your K is
bigger than log two over Delta then this
is kind of a constant right so it's a
constant time K over N and K has to be
you know large and unloved to over Delta
to get high probability bounce so then
that would be you know so that that that
would be said this is a constant
provided key is at least log 1 over L so
this is your P ok and your target L
Delta is something like this its minimum
of half and square root log 2 over Delta
ok so you know this could be a constant
so if your K grows as log 1 over Delta
then this is like a constant but if your
K grows a little bit faster then this
also goes to 0 right so K grows faster
then your Delta will also go to so and
your P is K over N notice and you know
since you you know if you want
consistency then you can get let UK
where and go to sit okay questions
okay so let me again give you a little
bit of intuition for this flow for you
know for what is going on around here
notice that if your H and K of X is not
equal to H of X right so if your
classifier is not agreeing with your
Bayes optimal then why why isn't it
agreeing with the Bayes optimal well you
know it could not agree because of
several reasons so let's see what could
happen one thing that could happen is
that X lies in that P Delta boundary
right if X lies in the P Delta boundary
bass is gonna give up on it right and
you know which is fine you know that
that's why that new P Delta shows up in
the Bob right so this is gonna get bad
one the other thing that could happen is
that let's say X doesn't lie in the P
Delta boundary right so it does lie in
the P Delta T here and however the you
know however your training data is such
that the distance to its K its nearest
neighbor is strictly greater than R P of
X right and you know which could happen
by chance so normally if you look at P P
is K over N times a constant right so
normally if you know things all went
well with high probability this sort of
thing wouldn't happen but it could
happen by chance right like this is
greater than IP of X so that's something
that could have happened
so that is why you're not agreeing you
get a lot of these points which are you
know not the right thing the other thing
that could happen is that these labels
could be you know really kind of noisy
and what could happen is that this
quantity you know this this this this
particular thing could happen right so
what this means is that if you look at
the ball of you know if you look at that
ball of rare probability mass P and if
you average you know the y Y is x x i's
in the ball - the ETA so this this
average should be you know close to etta
but if this average is more than Delta
away from ETA then you know maybe you're
you know maybe your points are fine the
points are live within this you know
within the right ball but what happened
was that you know just somehow the
average was off right so that is the
other thing that could have
so why why is that because so let's say
the one doesn't hold right so if the
first thing doesn't hold that which
means that X lies in the interior then
your ETA X is bound and and let's say
for now so you know it X is either you
know either your X's on the positive
side or the negative side so for now
let's just say X is on the positive side
in that case your ETA B is at least half
plus capital Delta right so this is the
condition this is how we defined our key
our p-delta interior so that's that's
how we define things right and then what
that means is either the kid nearest
neighbor of X lies outside B which is
condition2 or the averages you know
don't average and all the labels don't
average out properly he said this is you
know this is you know what we just
explained okay so now what we need to do
is we need to figure out how often do
these things happen what you can show is
that if you set B in this particular way
you can use a simple channel bar to show
that the probability of the second event
happening is at most Delta over two
right and that's in fact exactly how we
set up P this is YP you set up to be
this way
right so the probability of this event
is at most n over two very simple chain
of mountains and for number three again
if you set Delta to be this particular
quantity then the probability that
number three happens is also at most
Delta over two and again this is general
bounds right it's a very simple channel
bounce and and so this probability is
also relative right and now if you put
everything together essentially your
risk becomes probability that the Bayes
optimal doesn't give you the right level
plus the probability of the first event
which is X lies in this X lies in this
boundary P Delta boundary plus the
probability of the second event and the
probability of the third event right and
you know the first one is our star the
second one is just the Mew the
the measure of this boundary the third
one and you know these and these
we set up our P's and Delta's so that
this probability summed up to them right
and just you know putting these all
together you know we get this theory and
you know if you look at the paper this
theorem is just a bond page proof it's
just it's very simple it's just a
one-page proof the the the kind of the
the real you know technical thing is
setting up the definitions properly yes
that's a real contribution okay so okay
so now what else can we say about this
so previous in in previous work people
had looked at nearest neighbors under
various kinds of and this is you know
again similar to regression and similar
to the question that Vitali asked
earlier people had looked at nearest
neighbors had under various kinds of
assumptions so a couple of you know a
few typical assumptions or something
like this so one is holder continuity
and you know not just nearest neighbors
like a lot of nonparametric methods are
also studied under this assumption so
one is holder continuity and this HR is
said to be alpha holder continuous if
for some constant L and all X and X
prime the gap between 8 of X and 8 of X
prime is at most L times the distance
between X and X prime raised to the
Alpha right so this is alpha holder
continuity and then there are these
Civic of mmm on C book of margin
conditions which say that essentially so
again you know this is by the way this
is very similar to the Lipschitz thing
we talked about and here are again the
key to this is that there is one L right
one L globally that is the key to this
thing okay so that is kind of the
important bit over here right and so
this is you know similar to Lipschitz
only that it's raised to the power of
that okay then the second thing that
people have looked at is what are called
margin conditions right so this is the
mimosa book of
margin conditions for any constant C and
for any T the measure of XS such that
ETA X minus 1/2 is less than equal to T
is at most C times T to the better right
and here beta is a parameter
so what does this mean what this means
is that if you look at so basically what
this means is that there isn't a lot of
excess for which a tie X is too close to
a half right that's essentially what it
means so if you look at X's where ATAR
lies you know within 1/2 plus minus T
the measure of those X's is not that
much right so there aren't that many
points close to the decision boundaries
so in that sense it's a margin to this
right and there is also something called
the audible sigh buck of condition so
which is essentially the two above two
conditions plus a condition that mu is
supported on a regular set with mu min
less than equal to MU less than equal to
MU max so you know within constant
factors of the uniform distribution
under these conditions you can show that
expectation of the risk - our stead if
you set K properly then this is n to the
minus alpha times beta plus 1 over 2
alpha plus this capital D where D is the
dimensionality of the data right and
this can be achieved and this is also
optimal so this was this this is known
and this can also be achieved by K
nearest neighbors for suitable K okay
but now based on you know kind of this
way of looking at things what we can do
is we can talk about a different notion
of smoothness right and which will make
things cleaner which is n bits you know
we think is a more natural notion which
is instead of relating smoothness to you
know instead of putting down all these
conditions what we can think about is
you relate smoothness not to the
distance between X and X prime but to
the probability mass of a ball of radius
you know equal to the distance between X
and X prime right look at the distance
between X and X prime you look at X and
a ball of radius right if that ball is
like a high density ball then you know
then you have then you have to stay in
so that's that's kind of the that's kind
of the main idea right and you can
define this and we define this notion on
ATAR so we say it
Alfa smooth if for some constant tell
and for all X and R greater than zero
the gap between ETA at X and the average
a Tau over the ball of radius of a ball
of radius R around X is at most L times
the probability mass of the ball of
radius R around X raised to the Alpha
right so now instead of distances we
have probability mass right so what this
means is that even if your R is small
but you are in a high density region of
space your data can change pretty
rapidly right whereas if you're in a low
density region of space then Etta has to
change slowly right and this is kind of
this is the sort of thing that makes
sense for nearest neighbors right
because when you are in a high density
region of space your K nearest neighbors
are very very close so things can change
can change rapidly and if things do
change rapidly you will get some results
whereas if you are in a low density
region of space C or you know your
nearest neighbors are pretty far and you
know so then your data cannot change
that rapidly because then you can't do
so and you can under these Buddhist
conditions you can also get you know we
can get various upper and lower bound so
for example we can show that if your ETA
is alpha smooth according to the
definition that we just talked about
then for ya
so if your a tie is alpha smooth
according to the definition that we just
talked about then for any NNT with
probability at least one minus Delta you
can get a bound like this right so this
shows the risk of your K nearest
neighbour classifier that is at most
Delta plus the measure of the following
set so what is the set if you look
closely I decide the set is basically
what happens the set of all X's whose
eta is within 1/2 plus minus square root
1 over K log of 1 over Delta right so if
you look at the decision boundary and if
you look at all X's which are whose eta
is 1/2
that's - you know let's say 1/2 + minus
1 over square root K those X's you know
you have to give up on write those XS
you're not gonna do so a lot but the
rest you're going to get and for the
rest you just have that you just say
again it just comes from basically large
deviations and and and these X's you
have to give right so this is
essentially what your interior would
look like right so remember we talked
sorry this is essentially about your p
delta boundary would look like we talked
about the interiors and boundaries and
this you can get for I think a basically
proportional to n to the 2 alpha over 2
alpha plus 1 and then lower bounds you
could also show some lower bounds and
basically your lower bounds say that you
have to give up on these right and so
this part is sort of gone but you have
to give up on the concept of ability you
have to give up on all those x's whose
Etta is 1/2 plus minus 1 over swea so if
you think about you know those X's in
the margin whose ETA is like half-life's
minus 1 over square root okay well you
know with K nearest neighbors you you
won't be able to get them accurately
right so you won't be able to really get
you know you have to give up on them you
won't be able to get them out and you
know but if it sort of makes sense and
you know again notice that these are you
know very distribution dependent bounds
right so you can have distributions
where this is huge so you're giving up
on quite a lot of points or you can have
distributions for this
so you know so I showed you something on
smoothness I won't go into too much
detail because you know now we are close
to lunch you can also use this kind of
analysis to get faster rates for special
cases right so for example one
interesting case is what happens when
you have zero bees risk right so your
etta is exactly zero or one yes
[Music]
you know know this you know this these
two certainly don't this one mean I have
to look this up this for me but these
two certainly
[Applause]
actually you know there's this one
doesn't
okay so what interesting case is it I
mean they also look at several other
interesting cases in our in our paper so
what interesting case is what happens
then you have zero basis right where eta
is just zero or one and you know this
happens a lot of times and there you
know remember we had started by talking
about how you know one nearest neighbor
doesn't work right one is nemesis
inconsistent right but in those in that
particular case now that we are doing a
final analysis what we can show is one
nearest neighbor has the best rates
right and better than any other kay or
at least I mean that's the upper bound
right so we can show a better upper
bound for one Harris liebe than for any
other k nearest neighbor and if you
think about it carefully that actually
makes sense because in Kenya so when you
have zero base risk your pluses or
minuses are really just kind of
separated unless they're too too close
you know they're just kind of separated
and what would happen is if you do K
nearest neighbors then you have to look
at you know key points around you
whereas if you are and everybody has the
same area right so your neighbors all
have the same error so you would expect
one nearest neighbor to do well because
you just want to find one point from the
same class if you don't have zero base
risk then you need more to average
things over but if you do have zero base
risk it this is you know intuitively
that's what you would expect to happen
and we can you know we can show in terms
of upper bounds we can at least you know
get a better upper bound for one year's
labor than for the others the other
interesting case is you know we were all
this while we were talking about you
know 1/2 plus minus Delta by Delta could
get pretty close to zero right but what
happens if Delta is bounded away from
zero in that case we can also get
exponential convergence when when n is
large enough right so when we are at the
point where Delta is you know when n is
large enough where the radius is at the
point when Delta is bound enough or we
are from zero we can actually get really
good convergence and you know just the
fact that this is a finer analysis these
things just sort of show up and you know
and they show very nicely and cleanly ok
ok so in
inclusion we looked at basically clean
ears never regression and classification
we talked about whatever happens there
right so we started out with some
classical stuff we showed that Kenya
receiver is universally consistent
provided key grows in a certain way with
n right so this K over N goes to 0 and K
goes to infinity so this stuff is
important then we showed that you know
in Kenya receiver unfortunately we do
suffer from the curse of dimensionality
right the price of this much flexibility
is the curse of dimensionality and in
fact k-nearest they were regression you
really get to see this for
classification you you also get to see
it I mean there is definitely a curse of
dimensionality but the thing is that you
can do better if you are you know if
you're if you have good properties or a
hundred decision boundary right so if
your decision boundary stuff around it
is well-behaved then in ten years ever
classification you do get to do better
right and which is you know which is
better than regression for regression
the for regression the challenges that
you have to do well all over the space
right whereas for classification you
know this kind of this observation in
our work is that you know you really
only care about what happens around a
decision boundary and if there things
are well-behaved enough that can you
know that can get it getting true ok and
and finally I would like to thank you
know my Carter Chandra Das Gupta and a
lot of this work was a lot of the
classification stuff was based on joint
work with him and also part of this talk
is based on a tutorial that Shawn Jaya
and samuri kakuta face gave last year
and I'd like to thank them for their
help
in the present question yes can you know
much that slide with the upper lower
balance for classification
yes yeah so say yours time I help the
classification case still has the curse
dimensionality that doesn't come up at
least and I can see right now oh yeah
yeah so the margin if not you know if
you look at the uniform distribution
then it would come out you'd have to be
right so it doesn't be customized in
this area so under the same assumption
what about epsilon nearest image do we
get the same or even you fix the benefit
you use a fixed bandwidth interference
with ha the content classifies right you
know I don't exactly know so what kind
of classifiers the problem would be that
you would still depend on the rest of
the space
right so for nearest neighbor the thing
is after Kay you have a hard cutoff you
don't care about what happens outside
your viewpoint right after so so so what
she's asking of our art is asking about
is kind and classifies well you know you
have something like this right your
predictor is sum over X ie2 the minus X
minus X square divided by you know see
but they had the thing is your you still
depend on your entire training set right
so you still depend on the rest of the
space and the dependence grows weaker
and weaker as you know so normally you
would you know this would be a slayer
fan and it would already expect this to
go to zero but you never completely cut
off is I'm just talking about tricks
yeah I see yeah you know I I don't know
I mean we haven't we haven't looked at
that it's now all I'll tell you that
it's not as clean so we haven't looked
at it good question yes
okay
[Applause]